[Music]
[Applause]
peter king is going to join us
momentarily peter went to see the
raiders once see the buffalo bills here
is a comment from devonta adams talking
about going from one hall of fame
quarterback in green bay to a hall of
fame quarterback with the raiders
i mean anytime you change quarterbacks
from you know a hall of famer to hall of
famer you go you know stabler to rich
gannon or whoever you go to it's going
to be a little bit of an adjustment and
you know both are great players and
great to be around so i'm just enjoying
that process and getting better myself
you know trying to do as much as i can
to help these guys go out there and win
as many games we can
that's courtesy of cbs sports hq peter
king was with the raiders of course the
great columnist for football morning in
america
nbcsports.com what'd you make of those
comments that uh i'd like that he's he
believes in derek carr but uh hall of
fame quarterback
i mean
you know what's he gonna say
go from a hall of fame quarterback to a
nice quarterback i mean come on
i i mean i'll just say this dan we live
in an age where
every athlete
knows that being absolutely totally
honest
and saying that hey you know uh i was
with one of the
top 10 quarterbacks of all time and
aaron rodgers
and now i'm going to a pro bowl caliber
quarterback i'm really happy i'm
fortunate to be able to do it but let's
face it derek carr is not aaron rodgers
i mean so he can't say that
so he then has to say something that
obviously is a stretch
but i don't know it goes in one ear and
out the other to me
explain to me the love for the raiders
so far it feels like the media is on
this bandwagon early are you buying the
raider hype
well
they made the playoffs last year
and
in their only playoff game last year
they were very competitive and almost
beat the champion of the afc the
eventual champion of the afc
they added the best receiver in football
and a transcendent for them anyway past
rusher to team with max crosby i i mean
why wouldn't you be excited about the
raiders i think the raiders have a
chance to be really good unfortunately
really good
you also might have to overcome going
two and four or three and three in your
division
what's going to be really interesting i
think there's a bunch of early games
that are fun but like
josh mcdaniels told me over the weekend
he goes
you should go to that
our first game of the year and i had to
think for a minute
raiders at chargers z goes that's really
going to be a great game
because
the the chargers obviously made a lot of
improvements this off season and the
raiders made improvements this offseason
so every team in that division is going
to be better so even if the raiders are
better it doesn't necessarily mean
they're even going to be a playoff team
but i like what i saw when i saw him
this weekend but
you talk about teams getting better did
the chiefs get better no
they didn't they're the one but they've
won the division six years in a row so
you know somebody's still gonna have to
knock off the king
anytime you have patrick mahomes and
kelsey
and obviously a very diminished receiver
core but
but
you know
juju smith schuster
and this rookie skye moore i think is
going to be an impact player and we'll
see about marquez valdez scandaling um
but they're going to be good enough on
offense it's like everybody's saying
well you know the packers without
devante adams they're not going to be as
good has aaron rodgers always figured
this stuff out yes he does
so when i did my 32 teams 32 questions
in the column today i wrote about the
packers special teams and rich versace
coming in to me that's the biggest thing
that they have to deal with they lost
a playoff game
to a weak offensive team in san
francisco at home they lost it because
they couldn't play special teams
so that to me is a bigger question right
now in green bay because aaron rodgers
always figures it out
debo samuel situation kind of quiet
i don't i don't know dan it strikes me
that
uh john lynch is really going to try to
get something done under the radar
uh to try to keep debo samuel happy
look in the past some players in search
of a new contract report to training
camp don't practice
and
just it go to all the meetings and
so to not have a war
with that player a lot of times the team
just grits his teeth and says okay just
come to meetings and stay here and we
won't find you i don't know if that's
what debo samuel is going to do or not
if you're lamar jackson's camp
what what happens do you is there an
initiative on your part are you waiting
for the ravens to uh act on a contract
extension you know dan i've said all
along that to me i'd like to see lamar
jackson play well in the postseason
before
uh paying him more money than patrick
mahomes
to me
that's
and i still feel that way he's played
four play-off games he has not played
well in any one of those four games
and you know you're not signing a guy
for the long term because
uh he can play well in october you think
you sign him because you think he can
lead you to a championship now
it could be
that the ravens might say okay we'll
risk it we'll sign him for four years 47
million a year whatever it is
uh because if he does win a super bowl
or or plays great in the playoffs then
all of a sudden it's a flacco situation
we don't even remember this we didn't
even think about this but one decade ago
joe flacco was the first 20 million
dollar player in nfl history it seems
almost laughable to think about that now
yeah but he's the first 20 million
dollar player in history because he bet
on himself and he said i'm going to win
the super bowl next year be a free agent
and they're gonna have to break the bank
for me that's what they did if i were
jackson i wouldn't mind doing that
if i gave you a five-year contract to
give to either kyler or lamar you had to
give it to one
one of those two
i'd probably give it to lamar because
i just you know there's something about
kyler that worries me a bit you know
he's a small human being relatively
speaking
not that you know lamar jackson is a is
a sequoia
but
you know
kyler murray is gonna you know he part
of his game is his legs as is you know
the same thing with jackson
but i just i fear kyler murray i don't
think they're very different in terms of
what they can produce over the course of
a season
but i i worry a little bit about murray
staying healthy
we're talking to peter king football
morning in america columnist and of
course contributor with nbc sports the
market for jimmy garoppolo is what
i don't know
i i don't i really don't know
i mean
i keep thinking that he'll end up in
seattle and maybe he will but
the smartest thing for jimmy garoppolo
to do is right now to just tell the
49ers
don't do anything
i don't want to go anywhere till labor
day
even if i go somewhere then because
remember you know in 2015 when the sam
bradford thing happened you know teddy
bridgewater gets hurt in minnesota and
sam bradford gets traded for a gold mine
turned out to be a great deal for the
eagles because carson wentz was
you know was ready to play whatever year
that was i think it was 16 maybe 17 i
forget
but um
i think if i were him
unless i got some assurance from seattle
that
uh i really had a chance to be the
long-term guy
i would if i were him i'd rather wait
till to see what everybody's health is
on labor day weekend
you were with the buffalo bills it uh
seemed like it was boy band crazy for
josh allen up there with uh what the
fans hope for wish for expect out of
josh allen i i i haven't seen a reaction
to a player
in a in training camp like that i i
don't know if i i don't remember the
last time i saw a reaction they were
absolutely
bonkers for josh allen he's become
you know sean mcdermott said something
very interesting to me yes sir because i
complimented him remember uh in may when
there was the grocery store slaughter in
buffalo and the bills
they took like five buses everybody in
the organization came in and and stefan
diggs flew in he wasn't even at their
mini camp and he flew in to be able to
go and be with his teammates there and
josh allen stood up and he was the
spokesman for the team not the coach not
the gm not the owner it was josh allen
was the spokesman he was eloquent
and uh i think he has become
something of a bit of a civic icon there
very early in his career and what i i
should mention mcdermott said to me he
goes you know
athletes in a town can be hugely
important he said remember when david
ortiz stood up at fenway park and said
this is our bleepin city
and you know and everybody said oh geez
i mean that was you know little kids are
listening to that but david ortiz was
saying hey look
don't f around with us man because we
are going to come back with a vengeance
and i think josh allen in what he did
around the time of that shooting
really kind of propelled himself into a
bit of a civic leader status
is uh the time frame of the season
factored in with the decision with
desean watson
i mean i thought we'd have a decision by
july 25.
obviously the browns
need to know
and they need to know if they are going
to have to go out i mean if so well
robinson the arbitrator says
i agree we're going to suspend them for
a year
uh or i agree with the nfl's case we're
going to suspend them for a year
and then obviously it's going to be
appealed and all that
but so they have to know
uh and and again look i don't know
i don't know what the process has been
like but it's time for her to make a
decision she's got to do it this week
pete good to talk to you uh off to the
patriots coming up later this week
yeah going to the patriots and then uh
going to see the browns also and the
steelers
and then uh 18 teams total in about the
next uh three and a half weeks what
happens when you cross paths with
belichick
i don't know i haven't talked to him in
15 years
so i i
i don't i mean
i don't we don't say anything to each
other i i don't i don't really know i i
have not crossed paths with him many
times and i doubt i will in foxborough
this week have you put in a request to
talk to yes
i have a couple of times
he
has chosen not to
we actually reached out to him and we
said only talk army navy
that's it
and then we the response was he's
considering it
that's as close as we got to belichick
that he was
considering hey look you know i mean
that's that's the hazard sometime in
this job you have an opinion you write
things people don't like it they choose
not to talk to you this goes back to the
spygate thing
uh and
you know and it's just that's just
that's life that's life in the big city
and you experience it i experience it
we're all big people and life goes on
any anybody else that uh is on that list
pete that you're still waiting to talk
to
uh
there's a few people who
have been difficult for me but i i don't
think there's anybody else
who basically
uh who i put if i put in a request
wouldn't at least consider talking to me
i i'm really not as you know dan i'm not
really the big bad wolf
and uh but
i am gonna say like i
i when i go to cleveland
i would really like to talk to desean
watson even though i think his contract
is an absolute abomination
i i can't believe that the browns did
that
uh so i'm going to try to talk to all
the parties involved hopefully i can but
i guess uh you'll have to look at
football morning in america next monday
to see how i did i
i'm going to guess that the last 30
seconds might preclude you from talking
to deshaun
and it's just the way i feel yeah i
don't have anything against those guys
i really like i like those guys but you
know i i vehemently disagree with what
they did
safe travels pete always great to talk
to you okay hey thanks a lot dan that's
peter king football morning in america
we'll find out what he writes next
monday after he visits the patriots and
the browns and the steelers